Speaker 1: All right, I want to start today
with what's happening in the Israeli-Palestinian
conflict, where once again, we have another
major flare up and no clarity at this time
whether this will be on the order of weeks
or months in duration or possibly even longer.
Now, normally, I would just jump right into
the story and what's going on and my perspective.
But because of what I came into my office
to this morning, dozens and dozens of emails
and messages from people speculating as to
why I haven't talked about this yet, making
all sorts of accusations and allegations,
some of them very just sort of sad in terms
of what they imply people think is my life
on sort of a day to day basis.
And I've not spoken about this recent flare
up much yet, only three times on a recent
bonus show and a couple of times on recent
live streams.
I've not spoken much about it yet because
I've not felt that I have much to add or say.
That's different from my analysis the last
time we talked about it.
But I received a couple of emails from longtime
viewers respectfully saying this feels like
it could be different this time and it would
be great for you to update your take on what's
going on.
And so I'm going to do it.
I also received dozens of furious and often
emails playing on anti-Semitic tropes, referring
to me as a Zionist Jew pig and things that
are even worse that I won't say because of
our radio affiliates so that they don't have
to bleep things.
And people saying everything from you are
not talking about it because you're scared
you'll be exposed as the Zionist pig that
you are or its financial reasons or whatever.
So I'm under no illusion that those people
will be satisfied with this segment unless
I unilaterally put the sole blame for a 70
year conflict at the hands of genocidal evil
Israel.
And anyone who knows me knows I would never
give such childish black and white takes on
any issue.
And so those people who have been emailing
me saying I deserve to lose my show because
I haven't yet talked about it, I'm sure will
shift to saying I should lose my show because
of what I say today.
This segment is not for them.
Clearly, there were some really wacky things
being emailed to me, maybe on other platforms
as well.
I've really only looked at emails, but maybe
things are crazy on the discord or on Reddit.
I don't know people saying, well, clearly
I'm not saying anything because I'm afraid
of the blowback from from taking a position
my audience won't like.
That's never stopped me before on the show.
What I have said before is if there's an issue
that's unnecessarily inflammatory that most
of my audience seems not to care about, I
would consider skipping it.
But I've done dozens of segments on the Israeli-Palestinian
conflict.
Then I got email saying, David, you know,
you should really have the the courage to
do what this other Jewish person did and that
other Jewish person, they were able to put
aside their Jewish bias and take the correct
view on this, which is Israel is the only
problem in Israel in some cases even should
not exist, as some people emailed me.
David, why does your Judaism blind you?
You can't be a fair arbiter here because you're
Jewish.
This is the same argument that right wingers
made during the fight for gay rights, saying,
of course, gay people want gay marriage, they're
biased.
You can't listen to them.
They can't get past their personal connection
to the issue.
And it borders on anti-Semitic because it
plays on the trope of a dual loyalty that
American Jews have a conflicting loyalty to
Israel.
Most Jews, of course, have never been to Israel.
I've been there one six years ago.
I don't live there.
You won't be able to engage with me on things
like can't you put aside your Judaism and
take the correct position?
That's that's an identity politics rabbit
hole.
It's trash.
And I don't engage in that.
So I want to focus on what's been taking place.
Now, one last thing.
And again, I hate that I even have to do this,
but you should see what I stepped into in
my inbox when I when I got in this morning.
I also got email saying, David, you're motivated
by money, so you want to avoid losing money
if you give an unpopular take.
And so that's why you're hiding your view
on the subject.
And some people writing and saying, you know,
David, you used to cover the Israeli-Palestinian
conflict because you had a smaller audience
and you made less money.
Now there's too much money at stake.
I'm going to ignore for a second again the
anti-Semitic trope of Jews and money to say
that over time, as the show has been more
and more successful, financial considerations
are less and less a part of anything I do
at this point.
I never chose stories based on money.
I chose stories based on do I feel like talking
about it?
Do I feel like I have something to add?
Is this something my audience would be interested
in?
That's it.
It's just my show and I pick this.
Stories every day, financial incentives never
dictated story choice, they especially don't
right now, and by the way, if lots of people
are interested in the topic, then doing the
story would bring money no matter what I say,
hate watching is still watching.
It still makes just as much money.
So it's not only an incorrect take, it's wrong
on the facts as well.
All of that now out of the way.
All of the reasons why I've not been not doing
a story.
Now out of the way.
Let's talk about what's going on.
And if you want to engage with me on this,
engage with what I'm actually saying.
Not anything else that you're bringing in.
OK, there are arguably two catalysts to this
flare up and both have Israel to blame.
Both have Israel to blame, both have Israel
to blame.
Can I find ways to maybe say the catalysts
are more to say?
I could, but they feel disingenuous to me.
The narrow catalyst for this flare up is Israel.
The first is that a squad of Israeli police
officers entered the Al-Aqsa Mosque in Jerusalem.
This is a very volatile place.
I was there a few years ago.
Non-Muslims are only allowed at Al-Aqsa during
certain time periods.
Then I don't know what's going on now.
I was lucky to be there at just the right
time.
We were allowed in.
The Al-Aqsa Mosque is controlled by the Jordanian
authority within the old city of Jerusalem,
one of the most interesting places I've ever
been to the Old City in general and Al-Aqsa
itself, fascinating historical places.
A squad of Israeli police officers entered
the Al-Aqsa Mosque in Jerusalem, brushed the
Palestinian Jordanian attendance aside, went
across the courtyard and cut the cables to
loudspeakers that were broadcasting prayers
during Ramadan.
Disastrous idea.
Now, why did they do it?
The explanation is the Israeli president,
not prime minister.
The Israeli president was delivering a speech
at the Western Wall on Israeli Memorial Day.
You had Ramadan prayers conflicting with a
Memorial Day speech.
So the speakers were cut to terrible idea.
Now, you can argue and unfortunately, this
is how intractable this conflict is, where
many of us would say, oh, come on, just, you
know, give this speech somewhere else or turn
down the music or whatever that turned out
the prayers or whatever.
That's not the way this conflict works.
And if you've been following the 70 plus year
history of it, you would see why this explodes.
But I understand thinking what how is that?
What was the first catalyst then?
We had the upcoming eviction of six families
from the Sheikh Jarrah neighborhood, a Palestinian
neighborhood in East Jerusalem that led the
protests.
Then there was a police raid on the Al-Aqsa
Mosque on May 7th.
Police officers with tear gas, stun grenades,
rubber bullets went into the mosque compound
around 8:00 p.m. local time.
And this set off hours of clashes with protesters.
There were hundreds of injuries, according
to medics that were on site, as reported by
The New York Times.
The police say that the stone throwers started
at worshipers are saying the Israeli police
started it and then things exploded.
As usual, each side has their own view on
who the real wrongdoers are and who is merely
reacting to the other side, another intractable
bedrock of every single one of these flare
ups.
And there's plenty to go around.
Dozens and dozens of Hamas rockets coming
over from Gaza, even reaching Tel Aviv, Israel
doing bombings, as is always the case, Israel's
actions leading to more death.
Now, let me say one thing about this whole
disproportionate response thing that often
is is mentioned.
Yes, Israel's response is disproportionate.
That's absolutely true.
Israel is far better armed than the Hamas
terrorists in Gaza.
That's absolutely true.
And whenever this happens, there tend to be
more deaths as a result of Israeli action.
That's absolutely true and that's horrible.
I think that we should also be honest with
ourselves that some of the people who say,
well, if six Palestinians die and one Israeli
dies, it's a disproportionate response.
I don't think they would be pleased if the
numbers were the same.
I mean, would we really be seeing a different
reaction from people if 12 Palestinians and
12 Israelis died, would then would that no
longer be a factor?
I don't think so.
So, of course, the response is disproportionate.
Disproportionate responses are a common thing
in many conflicts, ethnic, political, military,
et cetera.
It doesn't mean it's good, but to focus on
that when obviously the side that's better
armed is likely to do more damage, I don't
think it helps us understand what's going
on any better now than Israel did.
Another completely harebrained thing, blowing
up a building in which the Associated Press
was working in Gaza saying there were Hamas
there.
Now, maybe there were Hamas, maybe they weren't.
Israeli authorities did call and say, get
out because we're going to hit this building.
Whatever is the case, Hamas is in all sorts
of different places.
And it just seems idiotic to me to target
this building because it does exactly what
Israel's opponents want to say Israel does,
which is suppress criticism and news of what's
happening in Gaza.
And in some literal sense, that's exactly
what happens when you will.
Blow up a building out of which the AP is
working, a disastrous idea, absolutely condemnable.
So let's go through these things first and
I'll tell you where I stand and pay close
attention, because, again, I'm not going to
engage in responses that mischaracterize what
I say I am and have been against evictions
and settlements, period, for the 25 years
I've been following this conflict.
There's no there's no mitigator.
I'm just I'm against it.
I condemn it.
This current Israeli government makes me sick
and has for a long time.
And settlements are a big part of that.
One thing that is important and that tons
of people are missing are that much like the
Palestinian people are different from Hamas
and the Palestinian Authority and the ultra
radical Palestinians, the Israeli people,
Israel as a country and the current administration
are three different things.
When during the Iraq war years, some Europeans
wrongly saw all Americans as war mongers who
wanted to go to Iraq, we all understood why
that didn't make sense.
We know the difference intuitively between
the Trump administration, the United States
as a country and Americans as individuals.
And yet more than half the emails I received
about this don't seem to understand or make
that distinction between the Netanyahu administration,
Israel as a country and the Israeli people
using the three terms interchangeably.
And that's just a fundamental misunderstanding
of what's going on.
How can we even have a remotely sensible conversation
about this conflict?
If you interchangeably assign blame or characterize
three separate entities, the current administration,
Israel as a country and the Israeli people
as one one in the same, the evictions from
East Jerusalem are at the heart of this, and
I'm 100 percent against that.
They are illegal by international law, period.
Settlers are radical extremists.
I share nothing with them.
I am diametrically opposed.
Settlers are a tiny fraction of Israeli Jews
who are just a portion of world Jews.
Unless someone says I'm for the settlements,
I assume that they are not because this is
such a radical and relatively fringe group.
Settlers are, in a sense, massive provocateurs,
shameless ones at that.
And sadly, right now, the Netanyahu government
is benefiting from the settlers and so they
are allowing this to happen.
Second, I am 100 percent against the Netanyahu
government, which I believe is allowing this
to happen for the benefit of Benjamin Netanyahu,
the depraved and disgusting right wing Prime
Minister Netanyahu knows his days are numbered.
He was unable to form a government.
So he is allowing this to happen now because
this is how he operates.
Look at the chaos.
You need me.
He pulled this before an election some years
ago.
Now, this is when maybe some people want me
to start saying who is to blame and to what
degree.
David, police say this conflict is 99 percent
Israel or say it's all Hamas or you are a
Hamas sympathizer.
Nothing is that simple.
What I will tell you is what I see as the
most likely path to peace for the long term.
And it requires both Netanyahu and Likud not
to be in power on the Israeli side and somehow
for Hamas to be removed from power in Gaza,
but not replaced by Hezbollah, which is essentially
as bad but better armed.
So here's my perspective.
If you said what is the most likely path to
peace, and this is why I didn't have much
to say initially in this, because fundamentally
the path to peace has not changed, in my view.
So starting with the big picture, anyone who
thinks that there should be no Palestinian
state in the future is just not a productive
participant here.
The Palestinians need a state of their own,
a contiguous one, which I will get to.
Anyone who thinks there should be no country
of Israel is also not a productive participant.
And if you really want to see a situation
where many people would die, it would be an
a real attempt, but by serious players to
make Israel no longer a country.
So the Palestinian people deserve a state
and to live in peace and the Israeli people
do as well.
And right now, neither side is being led by
those who benefit from peace or who want it.
Until that changes, nothing will change.
So the first question is, who's in charge
in a hypothetical peaceful situation in Israel?
It's not Netanyahu and it's not Likud.
OK, on the Palestinian side, Hamas must be
replaced by a more secular Palestinian Authority
immediately.
Hezbollah replacing Hamas won't get us to
serious peace possibilities.
Does Mahmoud Abbas have a role to play there,
currently overseeing the West Bank?
Maybe I'm open to that.
It doesn't seem Hamas is open to that.
When you look at how long Abbas has been around,
I think you can also increasingly make the
case that Abbas is not a likely arbiter to
a longer term peace.
Abbas has also given lie riddled speeches
at the U.N.
So has Benjamin Netanyahu to.
To the extent that Abbas might be a productive
partner, I'm open to it being a Mahmoud Abbas
led a coalition government, West Bank and
Gaza, but I don't know how feasible that really
is.
In all likelihood, you are going to need to
have the law of return for Jews to Israel
maintained and a law overturn established
for the future Palestinian state.
Now, the entire point of Israel is since Jews
were kicked out and discriminated of so many
parts of the world for so long, that's a place
Jews know they can go.
Even if Hungary turn turns extremely right
wing, anti-Semitic or anti-Semitic or whatever
the case may be.
There also is going to have to be, I believe,
some ability for Palestinians to return to
Israel.
Something is going to have to be conceded
mathematically.
And this is something Yasser Arafat talked
about in the 90s.
It's not going to be five million Palestinians.
It's just not going to happen.
So we need a combination of some reasonable
Palestinian return to what will be the state
of Israel.
Certainly the Palestinian state will be able
to decide who is allowed to go there as well.
Anyone who wants to move back to Gaza or the
West Bank would be free to do so if the Palestinian
Authority wants to allow it.
Now, Ehud Barak in the past proposed a symbolic
number of Palestinian return to Israel and
significant financial reparations.
That's something that could be looked at.
But but that's more details once we get past
sort of the big questions in terms of the
land, what are the borders?
Right.
I believe the most likely path to peace will
come with something that is more or less the
Clinton proposed borders or similar, which
is similar to a lot of the recent ideas, not
the Trump ideas.
Forget Trump Trump.
Anything Trump said is in the trash of the
Palestinian territory would include the West
Bank, Gaza and East Jerusalem.
Yes, East Jerusalem.
There are some problems with exactly what
the limits of East Jerusalem would be because
they are disputed.
But let's imagine if we got to this point,
they could be agreed upon.
East Jerusalem would become the capital of
the Palestinian state.
I think that has to be conceded.
And the caveat would be the Jewish quarter
of East Jerusalem should remain under Israeli
sovereignty.
We could do just a whole show on this.
But if you look at the desecration of the
Jewish quarter when it was not under Israeli
control from, I believe, forty nine to sixty
seven, you can read more about that.
I think that is a caveat on settlements.
I mean, just all settlements have to stop
immediately.
Israel has to agree in principle to remove
settlements that can be removed and to offer
meaningful land swaps for those that cannot.
Now, as a practical reality and I also go
back to what Arafat said about this, not all
the settlements at this point can be realistically
removed.
I hate that.
That's disgusting.
But if you say, David, you're the pragmatist
negotiator.
Morally, I have no problem with removing every
settlement.
And I know the talking point is, well, these
are people's homes.
Yes.
They're people's homes that were built in
violation of international law and they never
should have been built.
Yasser Arafat had the idea that keeping the
larger settlements in exchange for meaningful
land swaps would be OK.
That's probably something that would would
have to be negotiated.
And then certainly, on the other hand, you
know, all all settlements have to stop.
I believe the blockade has to be lifted to
Gaza.
You do have to have some way of preventing
weapon materials from being brought in.
It has to be negotiated.
But the blockade as a sign of good faith,
at least initially, has to be lifted.
Of course, Palestinians have to immediately
all Palestinian groups have to stop all rockets
immediately stop the tunnel building, so on
and so forth.
Hamas and other groups have to demilitarize
Gaza as part of a peace agreement we saw in
the two year period after the withdrawal of
Israel from Gaza, but before the blockade
was put in place, you know, thousands of rockets.
So there has to be a demilitarization, but
the Gaza blockade has to be removed.
And as long as the demilitarization and no
rockets are held to the deal, the blockade
has to be removed.
How do you hold people to that?
I don't know.
That has to be figured out.
And then lastly, the eventual peace agreement
has to include that all claims are being renounced
and it is the end of the conflict period,
because the problem you run into is you have
some sort of an agreement in principle, but
not all claims are renounced.
And then when the agreement is violated, everybody
goes back to pretending like this was never
identified as the end of the conflict.
If there's.
Going to be a serious deal once the right
players come to the table, and as I already
mentioned, who those are is complicated.
It has to be determined that that is the end
of the conflict.
And in the future, that allows any violator
of the agreement, either on the Israeli or
the Palestinian side to be held to account.
Some non-binding thing is not going to get
us what we need.
If you want to react, address the specific
points, all insults, anti-Semitic responses,
blanket replies, like what I had over the
weekend in my email, Zionist pig.
It's all going to be ignored.
The winners here are Netanyahu and Hamas,
chaos from which Netanyahu can say, you need
me to protect you.
That's a gift.
Hamas justified in its brutal grip on the
Gazan people because look at what Israel is
doing to us.
We're the only ones who can respond with the
rockets the Palestinian people lose here.
The Israeli people lose, Bibi wins and Hamas
wins.
I look forward to hearing your thoughts.
Remember that The David Pakman Show is made
possible mostly by members who sign up at
Join Pakman Dotcom, grab yourself a membership.